au rythme des mouvements d etat bascule
entre joe biden ou donald trump elles
ont suivi les résultats des élections
présidentielles américaines depuis leur
maison à marie sur mauldre précié sa
fille maya sont franco américaines elles
ont voté pour le candidat démocrate par
correspondance ce matin avait été dans
l'incertitude face à l'absence de
résultats définitifs je sentais une
sensation de neurocité de d'anxiété et
ça continue sacs en tissu le pays
vraiment dit viser des visées a
complètement en deux entre les deux
camps et elle a fait qu'une forme pas
déjà dit que clame d'être vainqueur mais
il conteste quand même
l'égalité à 2 certaines vote c'est le
chaos total
wyss consignes michigan pennsylvanie le
scrutin devrait se jouer dans ces états
soutiens de joe biden maya et sa soeur
tessa n'y croit plus vraiment je me sens
blasé parce que j'ai ce pressentiment
que trump a gagné que bien sûr avant ce
n'était pas le cas je me j'espérais
comme comme beaucoup de personnes mais
là avec avec les résultats actuels umiak
quelques state qui reste vhc dégoûté
mais aussi je sais qu'au fond de moi que
trump puis va gagner c'est presque sûr
devant leur télévision tracy maya et
tessa assiste à un débat entre amy
porter représentante des démocrates en
france et nicolas conc'air porte parole
français des républicains yvelinois
d'origine il soutient le président
sortant donald trump
à ce stade il faut encore être assez
prudent quand bien même on est assez
enthousiaste sur l'issue du scrutin avec
ces derniers états pivots les swing
states qui sont michigan with comme
signe pennsylvanie qui nous donne assez
favorable sur ses états c'est franco
américain vivant dans les yvelines ont
tous voté par correspondance
c'est le cas d'alice jousselin habitante
de saint germain en laye j'attends ses
patientes
j'aimerais savoir comme ça fait avancer
convient l'économie les résultats
définitifs de ces élections
présidentielles américaines devraient
intervenir dans les heures ou les jours
qui viennent